let's go to our caller from the eight
five six area code eight eight five six
we've got limited time but I'd love to
hear your question I
hey it's Jensen calling again I wanted
to ask you in a parallel universe
how does Hillary Clinton been elected
what Alex Ocasio cortes have made
headline because I think that she got
elected because of the gag reflex
because people are just disgusted with
Trump and ice wait a sec would who have
gotten elected the progressive who just
won in New York Oh Alexandria Acacio
Cortes yeah I mean at this point you
know we've got no way to a/b test that
right so there's a case to be made that
some of the progressive wins that have
taken place in the Trump era took place
because Trump won and did everything
that he did and if Hillary Clinton had
won then you would see number one a lack
of urgency to put in real progressives
and number two you might even have
Hillary Clinton as a centrist Democrat
helping other centrist Democrats win I
don't know the answer to that I think
that in all we can do is anytime there's
an opportunity to replace a corporate
Democrat with a progressive we do it
assuming it's a reasonably qualified
person I know people are already getting
on me for saying yesterday during a live
stream that although I agree with a lot
of Alexandria cassio Cortez's political
positions that I have concerns about the
depth with which she understands all of
those issues and you know I'm just I'm
just speaking my mind that doesn't mean
I think I would have voted for Crowley
if I had been in that race but I don't
know that that thought experiment is
that useful beyond recognizing then
there is definitely activism that has
been inspired by the election of Donald
Trump the question now is what will the
activists do with that enthusiasm or
lack of in the November midterms okay
all right thank you Dave all right
appreciate the call thank you glad we
were able to take some calls normally
don't take calls on the Thursday show
but we had a cancellation we will take
calls again next week talk to you that